[Music]
this is no ordinary jog around the park
it's a political loophole in Thailand
protests need approval by the government
running events do not an estimated
13,000 Thais disguised as runners say
they are fed up with the government of
Prime Minister Prayuth chan-ocha and
want him to step down Jabal ichabod well
I want to tell the government that the
people don't want you any longer you
have been in power for so long but you
can't solve any of the country's
problems that is getting more and more
difficult for grassroots people to make
a living this was the biggest show of
dissent against the government since
prayut assumed office after the 2014
military coup he held on to power after
elections last year with support from an
army appointed Senate this run protest
follows a rally last month staged by
Fenna Thorne is wrong room Gronk it the
leader of the progressive future-forward
party who has emerged as the most
outspoken opponent of Thailand's new
civilian government he was charged on
Friday for breaching a law on public
assembly and his party faces dissolution
I want to be part of the history I think
the first step in order to bring about
democratization in Thailand is that
general you has to get out that is the
first step that would allow that would
open doors to the process of freedom
organization in Thailand Sunday's event
was called run to oust the uncle in an
apparent reference to pry its nickname
of uncle to
it prompted a rival but smaller walked
to cheer the uncle event held in another
Park which was attended by thousands of
older ties private supporters say his
leadership has brought stability and
security I have to get all my friends
everyone to come and support my Prime
Minister I know you've got to help Larry
today I just flew from New York to come
here to support him in this three finger
salute made famous by the Hollywood
blockbuster film The Hunger Games is
banned in Thailand it's used here to
show resistance against the 2014
military coup with fingers held high
these jogging protestors are running out
of patience Lea harden al Jazeera